hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i wanted to talk today
about letters because
i think estate agents at the moment in
2021
house prices are going so crazy and
sometimes it can be difficult to get
deals
direct from an agent which is why we
send out
letters direct to vendor now when you're
sending letters out
i want to talk a little bit about who to
send them to
what to say in the letters how how how
to get a deal by sending a letter
so first thing you can send letters to
lots of different types of people
you can send letters to people that have
got negative equity in their houses
which you can find if they've got
negative equity by just looking at how
much they paid for the house
how much the house is worth now and then
you can you can suspect very negative
equity
boom send them a letter you can send
that some of these letters are
properties that we've driven past that
it's a derelict house
it's overgrown clearly no one's living
there
the person who owns the house isn't
going to be feeling pretty good about
owning the house
so what do we do we see it we finally we
find the address
on land registry which cost three pounds
by the way
you can just go on land registry pay
three pounds and find out who owns it
and then write a letter to the owner so
so so
and just and you wanted to say something
like hey i've seen your property it
looks it looks overgrown
i'd be really interested in having a
conversation the purpose of these
letters
is not to try and get a deal but to try
and get a conversation
so this is a sales letter trying to get
a conversation i mean that's how it
works
how many how many letters would you say
you typically send
to get one conversation get one
conversation
that's a good that's a good question i
would say
to get a conversation you probably need
to send out
10 letters to get one or two
conversations i mean our ratio is about
20
that get respond which is quite high but
that's because these letters
are a bright yellow so they get your
attention
and it's a good letter it's a well
written letter i said about 20 i agree
with that and i would say
half of those are just politely telling
you
right yeah 20 of people will respond to
you and some of them will just respond
and say
hey thanks for your message but right
now we're not interested in selling it's
like 10 isn't it
one ten one in ten ten percent okay but
but listen here's the biggest thing i'll
say about these letters
is you just need to keep sending them
and be consistent you know if you just
send out
50 letters we send how many of these do
we send that way like 25 30 a week
we send about 25 a week a week that's
not a lot of letters
but it's consistency and consistency
will win this race
so if you want to get a deal in property
or if you want to be a full-time
property investor developer whatever
rather than being like i'm going to go
all that like crazy like you see me do
on the financial freedom challenges
that's okay but my everyday life is
relaxed and chilled i'm just
consistently doing work in the
background
yeah i think that makes sense and are
you typically
looking for properties with planning or
without planning
okay so it depends on what the deal is
so if it's a house
a negative equity house then planning
obviously doesn't come into it
your question is very much tailored
towards property development because
right now that's
more of what we're doing um so if it's a
property development let's say a piece
of land
and we're looking to we're looking to
build our build on a piece of land
generally speaking firstly you don't
necessarily even know
what the situation is because we don't
do loads of due diligence on the site
before sending the letter but generally
speaking we're looking for properties
without planning
the profits in the planning so if if
there's a piece of land and it's already
got planning
that's okay if it's already got planning
it's going to sell at a premium
so we've been looking to buy land
without planning i mean we
you know i mean um but both it depends
there's lots of money and it's all good
yeah no it makes sense yeah um and
if you were advising someone on how to
get started in property development
yeah what would you start with small
deals start with small deals
build up to big deals you're going to
mess up on your first deal
so so you want to start with you with a
small bit and you've got like a list of
questions do you want to just read them
out too
yeah yeah my last question is
what do you do if planning is declined
if planning is declined
um okay so when you offer on the
property in the first place to buy it
generally speaking you're gonna make
three types of offers offer number one
is going to be a straightforward
purchase on the land as it is with no
panic
let's say the piece of land is um you
know half an acre
it's got no planning you have a good
idea if you think the planning is going
to get accepted or not because of the
what the area is doing
because of the the pattern you might
have an idea of the council is there a
shortage of houses in that area so
you're going to have as an experienced
property developer a bit of an idea if
you're going to get planning
so you can say look i'll buy it straight
off you and you'll offer maybe 200
000 pounds which is not a massive amount
of money for half a day because
certainly not where where we live in
fact how much did we offer on that piece
of land right near my house down the
road
we're 80 000 okay 80 000. 8000 how big
was that
that was for an acre of land an acre
right so that's
are you sure but nearly nearly an acre
okay so
80 grams for an acre is not
a lot of money so if you're going to buy
so there's three types of offers one
offer is just a quick
you know quick um bike cash offer if
you can't get planning it doesn't matter
that much because you only paid a small
amount for it you can just sell it to
somebody sell it to someone who wants to
land bank
no problem and to work out how much
you're gonna offer um
a little tip i heard from my friend
david taylor is he said that a piece of
land with no planning
is about the same price as an expensive
piece of
carpet and that is so so true so how
much does an expensive piece of carpet
for an ak probably about what you're
going to offer
to buy cash so so that's the first offer
second offer is you can offer to joint
venture with the owner and you can say
hey
um how about this i'll come i'll build
on it you can give me the land
effectively
and then and then at the end you agree a
price of what the land is worth now
and then you build on it and do what you
need to do and then you split the
profits 5050 or whatever you desired
and then they get their money at the end
that's a really attractive offer for you
because it means you put down zero money
and then the third option the one that
we usually do is what
options options uh an option would be
whereby you say i'll buy it for the
price that you want
which might be 200 000 pounds but i'll
give it to you in 12 months
and then in the meantime i'll start
getting planning you might put down a 5
000 pound fee
if you don't get planning they keep the
money if you do get planning
you push the value up and then you have
the option to buy it so
you know to be fair sometimes you can
offer them you can say look i'll have a
bite now
for like we did with that one you're
talking about we said little right now
for eighteen you bought on an option
for 180 yeah we'll do it as a jv and
you'll probably make about 350.
we've got some massive big things coming
okay on the development side
i mean a lot of us a lot of the deals
that we do are informed with joint
ventures and sometimes it's difficult
about doing what you can say what you
can't say
but what's your space because we've got
some really visual
stuff to show you on the development
side and uh yeah
so here's start small
send letters take action be consistent
get educated join me at the property
investors crash course for a whole day
my my 12 years experience in property
condensed into one day
given to you for free i mean how can you
hate on that so i hope to see you there
i'll leave a link in the description and
look forward to see you next time thanks
for watching peace out